you saw Messi's goal in his debut in
Miami what did you just realize about
Messi's greatness in that moment because
it was crazy of course it happened that
way you know it's just like it almost
doesn't surprise you anymore I mean what
what you know what we've seen from him
in the past decade even more what he's
accomplished what he continues to do the
World Cup finally and now him coming in
like that and uh you know seeing all the
you know the stars watching him play and
him coming in and scoring like that but
it really just doesn't surprise me
anymore he's so used to the big moments
and uh you know for him that's that's
probably nothing it's still special
nonetheless just watching him just
creating Magic on the field always so
it's pretty cool to have him here in
this country as well and I know a lot of
people are excited about that